bonjour bienvenue sur des gonades tv
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
joli chèque avec aujourd'hui jérôme mon
fera c'est jérôme en salle et stéphane
on va voir aujourd'hui un super champion
un peu moins connus que les que les
grands champions du monde que les fisher
les gars profs etc mais qui a marqué son
époque et qui a une vie tout à fait
exceptionnelle et qui était lors de sa
plus grande période considérée comme
l'un des grands espoirs occidentaux wii
du jeu oui il s'agit d'un briquet making
le brésilien et il a marqué non
seulement son époque mais il a aussi
marqué son continent puisque c'est
sûrement les meilleurs joueurs sud
américains de tous les temps et il a été
même le meilleur occidentales après le
retrait de fisher dans les années 70
sont on peut le dire oui c'est vrai et
donc ils absents meilleurs résultats je
crois que c'est au classement mondial
puisqu'il est arrivé dans la
en plein dans le développement du
classement elo donc là on a un vrai on a
vu une vraie mesure de la force des
joueurs je crois qu'il ya trois ans en
1977 il est troisième derrière karpov et
kornoi respectivement champion du monde
et vice-champion du monde et il est
troisième avec un îlot de 1650 je crois
peu près alors comment le brésil comme
ça d'un coup accouche d'un super
champion météores comme ça parce que
c'est ça une simple météores ils sont un
peu de désir échiquier ne connaissait
pas le brésil pour avoir fourni des
champions avant lui
qu'est ce qui se passe quoi
une école de chaque mois ci pourquoi pas
particulièrement et visez un peu hein
c'est ces grandes individualités
américaine ça commence avec mort fier
aux états unis même fischer aux états
unis n'est sur un terrain qui est pas
complètement vierge mais qu'est pas non
plus l'école soviétique
on a choisi raul capable en cas à cuba
qui devient champion du monde alors
qu'il avait jamais eu spécialement notre
effort genre cubain on amy winehouse
d'or en argentine qui lui est issu de la
communauté juive polonaise donc là il ya
peut-être une nation c'est une habitude
culturelle qui est plus forte et making
et oxygène c'est un de ces météores
d'ailleurs on l'a surnommé le phisheur
tropicale richard tropicale parce que il
a eu comme lui un début de carrière
absolument foudroyant puisque dès qu'il
met en 1952 il apprend à jouer à 6 ans à
11 ans il est champion régional et à
présent il est champion du brésil
13h13 ans avec 2 avec deux points et
demi d'avancé sur le deuxième le dette
le brésil est moins fort à l'époque que
même les états ou bien sûr quand même
construire des chèques non plus mais
d'accord et il ya 13 ans un champion
quand même un brésil le brésil c'est
qu'il ya quand même sûrement
vraisemblablement des 13 14 ans un des
meilleurs joueurs sud-américains avec
déjà un cours déjà donc on est face à
quelqu'un qui est une véritable météores
du des échecs
il obtient son titre de grand maître
international à 20 ans je crois 20 21
ans donc il a une progression très très
très très rapide lorsqu'elle musan que
tu parle justement de doudou vient
henrique making et d'où vient cette
tradition ou non tradition du d échec au
brésil
c'est amusant de noter kendrick et
making est originaire lui même d'une
communauté spécifique au brésil qui est
celle les germano brésilien en fait il
ya déjà des origines allemandes comme à
peu près 5 à 10% de la population
brésilienne c'est énorme
ce sont des allemands qui se sont
installés au brésil à partir de 1824
tu n'es des région rhénane de silésie et
qui se sont expatriés au brésil qui
apparaissait comme une sorte d'eldorado
comme toute l'amérique à l'époque et qui
se sont
qui se sont développés qui ont gardé
souvent leurs coutumes il n'est pas
impossible de voir dans le sud du brésil
notamment dans l'état de santa cruz azul
des gens qui me font toujours
l'oktoberfest la fête de la bière a
demandé de la faune toujours dans des
maisons à colombages et certains
continuent à parler allemand
il ya toute une vie traditionnel germano
brésilienne qui continue à exister et
cette communauté dont il est issu
bekking qui est lui même né dans cet
état en 1952 à donner des grands noms
brésilien alors dans leur architecture
je pense à oscar niemeyer qui est
l'architecte de brasilia dans la chanson
je pensais à ce trou de gilberto au
tennis je pense à gustavo kuerten au
football dunga qui était le capitaine de
l'équipe dans le brasier
et puis même chez top model gisele
bündchen qui est
et qu'un nom à consonance fortement
allemandes brésiliennes donc c'est une
communauté qui est très très très très
active au brésil et henrique making et
son et son représentant bauxite est une
tradition européenne
c'est dans le fait que les annonces
sûrement apporter le jeu avec eux au
brésil mais bon comme toute l'amérique
du sud qui est un mélange aussi de
beaucoup de d'immigration européenne
l'argentine c'est plutôt l'italien est
donc le brésil c'est très bien et on
s'apprécie de ses traits mélangez bien
sûr avec avec des portugais mais aussi
suivant les régions des allemands des
italiens
l'amérique de manière générale s'est
constitué sur sur un fort cosmopolitisme
donc tu me disais grands maîtres à 21
ans 21 heures donc si on est en quelle
année d'internât on est en 63 70 par
type rapidement à l'internal pour le
titre mondial
il se qualifie même pour le zonage de
sousse ensuite à nouveau il a il
continue à se qualifier mais il atteint
sais je vais pas dire qu'il atteint ses
limites mais il est quand même bloqué
dans son ascension par ce camp en 74
il se qualifie pour le tournoi des
candidats mais il est battu en quarts de
finale donc 58 ans résultat c'est déjà
un résultat mais il bloque à ce niveau
là dans l'est dans les dix premiers
mondiaux de nouveau en 77 il se qualifie
mais il est battu par paul games qui en
quarts de finale aussi donc il a il est
confronté à une limite au plus haut plus
haut niveau au top niveau en dépit du
fait qu'il ait quand même troisième
mondial et il se prépare comme comme
jamais pour le l'interzone al de rio de
janeiro qui doit avoir lieu en 79 lehman
brothers ou en plus à rioz il est sur
ses terres donc soutenu il est très
populaire au brésil 1
les surnommées quinio il fait plusieurs
fois la couverture de journaux grand
public
il est connu par l'homme de la rue donc
c'est vraiment là internationale à rio
il est sur son terrain il est préparé
considéré un peu comme le successeur de
fisher moment donné on y croyez que ça
pouvait être le nouveau fer de lance
occidental après le retrait de fisher
c'est le meilleur joueur occidentale en
termes de classement donc on attend de
lui qui éventuellement ils prennent
d'une certaine façon sa succession et il
est préparé comme jamais pour cet
international de rio de 79 mais au bout
d'une ronde il est obligé de quitter le
tournoi d'abandonner il a il est malade
et il est médecin diagnostique
rapidement une maladie très grave de la
myasthénie qui s'attaque au système
nerveux
on pense que la maladie est incurable
que making va mourir donc il se retire
complètement des échecs pour se soigner
et se tourne même vers la religion et
devient très fervents pratiquants de la
religion chrétienne catholique est plus
que ça puisque ça et devient il fait des
études de théologie pour devenir prêtre
elle le miracle se produit miracle de la
médecine au miracle de la foi en tout
cas making guéri et fait un come back
dans les échecs plus de dix ans après en
1991 il représente à nouveau le brésil
aux olympiades
il gagne un tournoi en italie est parti
même au grand tournoi chorus dans les
années
années 2000 oui ben sassi qui rien
notamment un très fort joueur dont qui
là encore il a encore des ressources
même à près de 60 ans il est persuadé de
pouvoir revenir dans les meilleurs
mondiaux ce qui me sentais très fatigué
il pense revenir avec la foi et son
talent il pense revenir dans les 10
meilleurs mondiaux
on attend pourquoi pas pourquoi ça cette
voie la longévité qui date quand on va
les manger vite et de coeur de corps
jetés avec c'est sur ce qui est certain
c'est que quand il a quitté les échecs
il était un très très haut niveau
il est vraisemblable qu'il puisse
retrouver un très très bon niveau c'est
presque une île à être presque vraiment
le parallèle avec fisher parce que il
atteint son son top niveau finalement
dans les années 70 et en comme fish a
lancé aux poissons d'eau douce donc a
rejoint sa secte on peut je sais plus ce
que c'était exactement mais alors lui
mais lui c'est plutôt vers la religion
je dirais un peu plus officielles
d'agents et il devient prêtre donc il ya
quand même derrière il ya eu 7
finalement cette cette aspiration pour
les deux joueurs de
retour à l'aspect religieux finalement
oui dans le calme et king ça se comprend
d'autant plus qu' il était sa maladie
était censé le condamné donc c'est
tourner un peu naturellement vers la
religion c'est que les brésiliens sont
un peuple de manière générale assez à
ses fervents en termes de croyance donc
lui s'est tourné vers la religion au
moment de sa maladie ensuite il ya
sûrement puiser la force nécessaire pour
vaincre la maladie depuis bien sûr il ne
se sépare pas sur les photos il se
sépare pas d'une petite croix pour
rappeler son engagement
on va regarder quelques photos enfin
deux photos de man riquet making alors
ici c'est une photo où l'on voit un
making b très jeune alors probablement
un tournoi déjà c'est pas une partie à
la maison parce qu'il a on voit pourquoi
on dit on parce qu'on veut tout de suite
qu à sa droite il à la feuille de partir
et ils vous posez dessus c'est à dire
qu'une autre les coûts ne pas les coups
à l'entraînement comme ça c'est
forcément déjà un tournant vote
d'ailleurs que la petite cravate un
petit costume il a tous les enfants
prodiges c'est amusant parce que c'est
une photo sûrement de là la fin des
années 50 voire début des années 60
et elle le fut pensez aux photos de
jeunes prodiges comme les chips qui dans
les années trente et un petit peu elle
est un peu intemporel on pourrait croire
que c'est une photo des années 30
ouais surtout c'est un échiquier avec
des grosses pierres grosses pièces ça
fait de penser aux jeux anciens fiction
et puis une pendule caleiras est assez
ancienne aussi est un beau jeu incrusté
dans la table ouais donc on va voir
maintenant alors ça c'est la faute aux
historiques de la jeunesse de making of
making beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus âgées et surtout ici voilà
avec la croix la croix autour du cou
c'est en 2006 de 54 ans qui est
photographié avec une jeune joueuse
d'échecs est encore très populaire au
brésil mais il est connu il est vraiment
connu par les brésiliens ml dans un
tournoi il continue il continue à jouer
même si c'est pas au même niveau bien
entendu mais voilà il a triomphé comme
une maladie qu'on avait diagnostiqué
comme étant incurable donc tout tout
partie d'échecs pour lui maintenant du
bonus on peut le dire comme ça
ouais voilà henrique mais qui alors
combien de temps a duré son son black
out entre le moment où il est au top et
le nom il revient à 79,91 une douzaine
d'années il disparaît de des échecs
d'une douzaine d'années et après leur
voix effectivement dans les tournois
alors plutôt du tournoi de dison de de
moindre importance pour pas dire 210 au
nom non pas seconde zone mais disons pas
tout à fait le top du top et on voit
qu'on ne va pas le voir à linares on va
maintenant tenter mais encore bus ou
chorus on va le voir au chorus sur le
voir il gagne un tournoi en italie à
l'audi dans les années je crois que
c'est en 2006 et cette année là me
semble-t-il bon même si ce ne sont pas
des c'est pas les tops tournoi ses
premiers tournois c'est parce qu'il a
joué fischer
ils se sont ils se sont rencontrés je
crois quand même qu'il a qu'ils avaient
un score de parité contrefiche
je crois qu'ils ont disputé un match
dans les années un petit match sans toi
un petit matin lundi match en cinq
parties quelque chose comme ça on est
d'accord
à voir à vérifier doit vérifier on a
passé pas même si en plus on n'a pas
creusé expressément d'accord voilà donc
making qui faut pas rater parce que
voilà c'est oui c'est ça fait partie de
ces de ces étoiles qui brille dans le
ciel du jeu d'échecs c'est bien aussi
comme ça qui est des joueurs qui sortent
qui sortent pas justement des machines à
fabriquer des champions et c'est bien
qu'il y ait des encore des toujours des
personnalités qui se font un peu leur
place était tout seul
oui et puis on aime bien tous ces
francs-tireurs comme corchia oil un ton
qui sont souvent de faire des très
fortes personnalités qui sont un peu
fait tout seul dans un environnement qui
était pas spécialement pressée propice
aux échecs ou qui ont eu des obstacles
des difficultés puis qui ont quand même
continué à jouer à s'affirmer sur
l'échiquier
tout à fait donc on va maintenant
revenir au plateau et puis on va passer
à une partie bien sûr de henrique making
alors ici c'est la fin ne va pas
regarder la fin va voir le début de
cette partie en trop alors pas n'importe
qui d'abord making mission parce que
c'est l'émission qui lui est dédié mais
en face de lui il a du lourd parce qu'il
est face à michaël talent le grand
michael talent au tournoi de las palmas
donc une partie qui s'annonce tendu face
à un
l'ex champion du monde connue pour son
style très offensif
voilà connu pour son style offensif
michael talent a toujours été considérée
comme on l'appelait le magicien riga
donc shirov un peu son héritier on veut
dire un bruit oui c'est à dire que c'est
des joueurs comme ça qu'ils vont tenter
d ouverture extrêmement tendue sur le
fil du rasoir et parfois avec même un
peu de jeu un peu approximatif mais
toujours qui pose des problèmes
tactiques énorme aux joueurs qui
arrivent à trouver des combinaisons
fantastique dans des situations
improbables mais on disait tels que il
sacrifiait souvent il développait ses
pièces et ensuite il sacrifiait des
pièces au milieu de l'échiquier
quand on lui demandait comment on fait
il images sans mes pièces ensuite j'ai
sacrifie et souvent ils créent des
complications qui étaient énormes et lui
même
on n'était pas sûr qu'ils y perdaient
par un petit peu mais son adversaire 6
perdait toujours un peu plus que lui et
donc à la fin à la sortie de la mêlée il
avait toujours quelque chose une pièce
en plus sain plus en plus une position
supérieure ce qui va permis quand même
de devenir champion du monde
à une époque où le jeu scientifique
rationnelle des années 50 un petit peu
stériliser le jeu d'attaqué donc c'était
une bouffée d'air quand même me cui oui
c'est un joueur dont qui se complaisait
dans les positions chaotique en idées
mais le quart où il aimait provoquer des
positions les plus n'est plus chaotique
possible alors donc on est sur eux
quatre ces cinq cavaliers
trois des six des quatre bon tout ça est
normal on ouvre le centre ici c'est
prendre les prendre
quels livres 6 qui a laissé 3 et à 6
voilà donc on est typique dans une
sicilienne l'âge d'or fini avec voilà
les deux fameux coup un des six et cinq
ont échangé en d4 on joue à 6 alors à 6
à la fois protéger la classe b 5 qui
s'ils empêchent des pièces de s'y poser
mais aussi près par la poussée b5
l'idée étant de pouce éventuellement b4
de pousser mais quatre pour les alliés
ne puissent plus protégé le pion aux 4
qui attaqué par le cavalier noir
enrichissement l'arrêt puisse faire une
expansion et les dames c'est déjà une
pseudo attaque de minorités deux pions
contretemps ici bref
enfin on n'en est pas là il ya plein de
possibilités encore ses idées générales
alors fou g5
voilà donc une des variantes de cette
ouverture le 6
normal alors aussi ce qu'on joue aussi
simplement avec une parfois souvent de
jouer ici aux cavaliers enfin fou fou
hausse est donc c'est un coup c'est un
coût normal on veut faire le petit rocha
cevital en f4 et là on va rentrer dans
la fameuse variantes ou la case il
oriente de piau empoisonné ou mieux une
oui c'est ça c'est même tout à fait
servir le cap des 600 penser que l'on
peut donner c'est lequel le pion poser
ses deux pions b2b de lancer ces fischer
tu jouais beaucoup ça avec les noirs
parce qu'il disait fischer en fait était
très pragmatique à la fausseté est
fantastique joueur d'attaqué mais aussi
un très fort joueur convié positionnelle
et il avait un côté matérialiste dans le
jeu c'est assez nettement marqué c'est à
dire qu'ils n'hésitaient pas à les
prendre un pion même en subissant
derrière une grosse initiative une
grosse attaque ça lui faisait pas peur
pour après jouer une finale avec un
point de plus par exemple ce genre de
choses
donc ce sont des joueurs qui qui jouait
la position sans se poser des questions
métaphysiques sur ses actifs par actif
c'est pas la question c'est je peux
prendre un pur jeu le prince officier a
pris à la réunion reste un pion comme
voilà d'armes des deux ici or c'est le
coup le plus dynamique
c'est à dire qu'on laisse les noirs
prend de tomber devant prendre b2 le
ku'damm d2 sert aussi à protéger le
cavalier c3 après la prise voilà on
protège aussi lutter et bien sûr après
la prière les deux joué sa force la
prise ici parce qu'on menace est grande
car notre coran menacer la justice il a
bien sûr l'aller un journal d2 les
blancs menace de faire grand que le fut
d'abord fini leur développement avec une
dame qui de mal placé parce qu'elle
empêche la fameuse poussée des 5
en général cette dame ne développe plus
tôt on sait 7 ou plutôt cinq donc cette
variante ici oblige la prescription donc
c'est volontairement que making invite
talent a complété sa finalement ça n'a
installé au bout de son idée est de
prendre en compte
en compensation de quoi après cavaliers
b3 vient on protège ici la tour et puis
cette dame se fera chasse et tôt ou tard
sans doute pas un tour b1 avec une tour
active une dame qui va avoir des
problèmes de placement être obligé de se
mettre en a trois ou l est pas du tout
active elle peut être pourchassés
pourquoi pas il peut y avoir des menaces
eux contre cette dame on peut imaginer
le cavalier qui reviendrait aux santons
tomber 3 qui la chasse le nouveau bref
en tout cas cette dame a des soucis en
échange du pion les blancs gagne des
coûts donc surtout que le coup suivant
des blancs pour être à 4 par exemple
alors il ya une menace bien sûr après
aussi tout à fait après l'arrivée 3 il
faut le signaler c'est à 4 et la dame
n'a plus de cases parce qu'on a enjoint
4 on prive la dame de la casa 3 donc la
dame est quasiment prise
fit jouer tour à deux et ou autour ab1
et perdu non pas trois pattes robert
sera de ne pas tomber un tour à deux ou
même
même qu'à valider un imaginons on va le
faire
imaginons que les noirs jouent pas moins
de sept tiens on va provoquer exprès
bonjour on peut prendre d'abord prendre
pour se débarrasser de la présence on
prend ici et après maintenant regarder
on joue à 3 par exemple
et c'est fini la dame éprise ne peut pas
sortir on joue à trois pour éviter même
si elle que font les noirs si bon je
suis pas moins un coup comme qu'elle
laissait 6 par exemple je sais pas on
peut jouer qu'à valider un par exemple
ou tour b1 et la norme n'a pas de gaz
elle refait un tour particulier un tour
à deux bien sûr ou alors cavaliers dncg
ainsi qu'à plus de cases
voilà donc qu'à aller b3 c'est pourquoi
les noirs jouent damas trois donc il
faut faire attention si vous jouez ces
deux variantes
faites attention la dame est vite pris
au piège notamment que ce qu'avaient mes
trois lacs qui menacent de l'enfermer
c'est ainsi dieu sait si dieu donc ici
ben on en profite pour faire [ __ ] en
abscisse l'idée de vous prendre 6 bat
ces deux cas c'est ici la structure des
pions noirs on est obligé de reprendre
du pillon et en plus on est vite
la possibilité fawcett qui contrôlait
ici le cavalier donc j'y prends m6 et
bien on a une dame hors jeu on a deux
pièces sorties on n'est pas loin d'avoir
fait on ne peut pas faire le maroc va
faire je fous ces quatre offres eux deux
et on peut faire le petit rock et on
peut commencer à attaquer et c'est pas
clair avec les normes de se dire qu'on
m'a raconté de ce côté la société
fischer ok quand même qu'on a c'est à
dire qu'il joue et ça y est rauque et il
n'avait pas peur de manquer de ce côté
là il a fait des partis comme ça donc
faut 2 voilà qu'elle et ses six tout ça
est normal on développe les pièces faut
pas traîner avec les noirs voyez comme
le retard que vous avez vous avez juste
une dame qui en plus peut être peut être
chassé par les blancs et vous avez
aucune autre pièce sortie c'est de
casser si c'est la deuxième pièce alors
qu'il y en a 1 2 3 4 des côtes et blanc
est bien pour la dame noire aura du mal
à revenir en jeu faut qu'elle revienne
mais où les 4 et 15 ans b 6 si c'est
bien c'est 7 pour pouvoir se replacer
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué en
attendant les là il vaut mieux la
laisser là je pense mais la voyez comme
elle est peu active notamment sur le
centre
donc petit rock et la taille joue le
coup c'est automatique
page 5 voilà un jeu simple pourquoi pas
un vus alors là par contre il abandonne
toute possibilité de rock et sans doute
qu'il soit resté au centre et
éventuellement faire le grand roque
quoique avec la colombe et un mois je
je n'aurais pas trop surtout avec madame
e place est ici un don qu'il veut
peut-être laissé le roi au centre est là
en jouant h5 bon il peut préparer des
coups comme fou 6 et faire une petite un
petit coup à joly si surya dames 1 puis
va peut-être se prémunir d'un coup comme
fourrage cinq exactement qui pose pour
la mettre la pression sur le pion eu six
puisque le pion à vii et cloud est
maintenant tiré tout à fait voilà une
autre menace positionnelle de jouer
fouet 5 avec un fou qui tape sur la
faiblesse h7 qui cloue ce pion ici tout
de suite là le dr laurent rock sera très
dur parce que j'ai cette emprise voilà
donc ici h5 à la fois protège
sur peu menacés parfois faux à 6 ce
genre de choses et là haut calibre et je
harcèle voyez que cette dame est harcelé
où va la dame faut pas revenir en b2
puisqu'on se reprendrait à 3 la tour est
protégée de se reprendre à trois on
rejoue rica les c3 rios on mettrait
deuxième tour ici essayé on serait pris
au piège non madame b 4 belles et noir
ça les arrangerait de faire un échange
de dames
mais c'est pas l'idée de making bien sûr
making jouda me 3 noter qu'on peut pas
faire needham c5 et ça nous arrangerait
de faire une cloison ya le cavaliere ni
dame déclare puisque avec la veille
aussi donc dames 3 et puis je peux
attention parce que je contrôle quoi
bien je contrôle la casse p 6 donc je me
lasse presque de gagner la dame qu'est
ce qui se passe après à trois voies la
dame ya plus qu'une case c'est la case à
4 sur quoi cavaliers c3 et la dame ait
perdu l'éclair de huit chapitres case
oui ça va vite c'est c'est encore une
fois insidieux de me 3 c ça fait peur ça
fait peur
donc ça explique le coup suivant en fait
tu l'as déjà les voyez comme les noirs
n'ont pas le choix des cinq haye
alors moi ça fait peur de jouer ça alors
des 5 quel est l'intérêt de dessins etc
évidemment c'est de pouvoir
définitivement ramener la dame à la
maison un jeu must ouverture finalement
je vais jouer c'est un maintien mais il
faut que les noirs vous c'est un nom
d'artiste les yeux le problème de d5
c'est quand même que le roi est encore
au centre et on propose ni plus ni moins
que de voir la position alors ça fait
peur puis alors plus c'est une victoire
pour les blancs parce que regarder on a
laissé on a fait prendre le pion de v2
messi pour l'échanger contre le pion
central des 5 c et 10 c du rêve donc
évidemment que je prends alors on prend
alors regardez en plus on a prises on
peut pas reprendre puisqu'il ya la dame
face au rond en auxois poincloux et en
plus je gagne en temps je gagne du
mouvement puisque ce qu'elle est c'est 6
doit bouger et il va en sept voiles
alors là en venant 1,7 y y contre
attaque sur la case
des 5 mai le coup suivant des blancs et
fort c'est simplement le coup que les c3
très bien je sors la dernière pièce
légère je prépare pourquoi pas la
centralisation des tours je pourrais
peut-être plus tard même poussé f5 et
lequel ses trois protégés dé 5,6 les
noirs prennent avec le clavier je
reprends le cavalier est imprenable donc
c'est pas possible on perdrait une pièce
pareil si je prends du pillon cavaliers
prendre des 5es jeux menaces câbles
hypron m6 avec un quasi match donc c'est
pas possible et noir semblent
extrêmement mal déjà dans cette position
bon évidente talent à calculer tout ça
et quand on joue cette variante du point
pupilles on oppose donné on s'attend à
vivre ce type de position donc il vaut
mieux avoir préparé avant tablier 5
voilà c'est celle d'autres idées noires
maintenant c'est de jouer 9 5 qui
attaque à son tour la dame blanche
regardez ici d'ailleurs on comprend
mieux lier du coup h5 parce que ça
empêche toute possibilité de chasser ce
cavalier qui est magnifique on parle à
l'heure il est très bien ce cavalier on
pourra pas le chasser par g4 est
lui-même peut aller angers quadrillage 6
éventuellement on peut envisager mais
ceux ci vivent bon [ __ ] de développer
le fou mais effectivement on pourrait
envisager qu'alexis la gca pourquoi pas
mais là on est bien ici finalement bien
parce qu'on est protégée en tombant
contre les cadres dans le détroit
très bien on est bien des trois aussi
avec la dame à noter que vu que les
pions sont sur blanc n'y a pas deux fois
ci c'est embêtant ultérieure de toute
façon on protège des cinq pas de
problème dans bay 6 échecs on ramène la
dame à la maison avec un petit échec ici
attention attention que là il ya des
tentatives de maths qui peuvent avoir
lieu parce que si on joue un coup comme
roy h à regarder on peut envisager le
coup fort h4
pourquoi h4 parce qu'on menace regardez
bien échec on ne peut pas venir en juin
puisqu'elle adam prise forcer les
cavaliers et si on prend une option pour
en prise avec échec de la toile et ses
maths c'est quasi matin il faut jouer ou
hcng pourpre en maths c'est matt donc
chaud donc mais qui ne voit ça ah bon il
n'aime pas trop alors il ya sans doute
des coûts pour paresser menace mais donc
on n'a pas trop envie donc on va jouer
tous rêvent de voilà on évite un de
rentrer de se mettre en vis-à-vis de la
tour on joue tous rêvent 2 n'y a pas de
possibilité pour les noirs ici de
rajouter de la pression a noté que le
fou le couffo c5 et simplement pas
réparé cabaye prend donc il n'ya pas de
n'y a pas de souci donc ç'a permis au
noir par contre de jouer le ku'damm 3
est donc de proposer un échange de dames
vu la position du roi noir vu la
prééminence du développement blanc du
pion des cinq qui quand même et bien
placé donc en or qui peut à tout moment
ouvrir les lignes sur six il vaut mieux
échanger les dames si possible alors
meeting jouent alors je ne peux pas trop
bouger adam malheureusement c'est vers
qui on aimerait bien garder la dame il
faut trouver un coup actifs alors est-ce
qu'on peut jouer un coup comme par
exemple dame c4 c'est ce que je suis en
train de me demander d'hamsik la très
possible
voilà mais sa soeur tout ça pourrait se
heurter à foug 17 avec derrière tours c8
et j'active mes pièces avec gain de
temps notamment depuis la menace en plus
de gagner le cavaly c3 donc c'est pas
très très très bon et c'est pourquoi
making joue plus actif il joue cavalier
de quatre ans leurs cavaliers ou 4 c'est
un bon coup on laisse les noirs prendre
même en d3 et surtout bien on va
attaquer réussissent à noter que ce soit
facile à défendre à vis ici
pourquoi alors si on joue fou g7
on peut jouer cavalier échecs et les
bleu et noir peuvent pas prendre puisque
ce cavalier doit garder le contrôle sur
la dame et après on pourrait reprendre
25 et en cas des charges on se
retrouvait des pions triplé très clair
ce n'est pas bon du tout c'est des pions
archi bloqué qu'on va pouvoir
gobé avec délectation et facilité donc
si on joue par contre de l'autre côté en
7 on peut se heurter pourquoi pas la
poussée des six voilà ça peut être
pénible aussi il faut au fola calculer
mais c'est tout à fait jouable
alors donc voila ce genre de choses donc
ils échangent talent up
enfin comme ça c'est réglé bon la menace
calais prend m6 est toujours là il faut
faire quelque chose dont il faut s est
alors bon heureusement des six ne marche
pas puisque il ya le cavalier et le fou
qui sont en protection donc on va jouer
ici tour 1 mais qui met sa tour toujours
toujours bien admettre une tour
vis-à-vis du roi mais au lieu de
défendre l'option des 5 ou traiter le
problème du pion des cinq trouver une
solution oui ces deux jeux taurins parce
qu'en cas de prise maintenant on a
cavaliers pas réussi ces chèques et le
fouet cloud et on ne peut pas prendre
avec le fou et on va ramasser le pion
un deuxième pion avec des cinq et on
ramasse le clan des cinq exactement tout
à fait donc tour est un roi des fuites
normal 1 nous a vus comme tout à l'heure
on a évité de mettre le roi blanc en
vis-à-vis de la tour et inversement
quand une tour vient en vis-à-vis du roi
on aime bien sortir le roi parfois par
un rock d'ailleurs mais la voyez la part
où il aurait pu rock et d'ailleurs même
parce qu'il a peu bougé noir et la
prolonger la tour j'aurais pu il aurait
pu rockets il aurait laissé le pion aux
cinq isolé d'ailleurs il est isolé ce
pion est tout seul
et tout cela sur son idole abc le
problème d'avoir dû reprendre ici dû
plonger c'est le souci notamment de
cette ouverture est bien sûr c'est pas
un souci tant que le jeu est actif
dynamique qu'on est au mieux de partir
maintenant
la finale se profile après l'échangé des
dames et ont saisi que cette faiblesse
elle va continuer à grossir
voilà c'est une faiblesse qui peut
s'avérer être une cible en finale c'est
ce qu'on verra par la suite alors ici
des prend 2,6 de la part des blancs au
bon moment il aurait pu aussi jouer les
capes ouais on aurait pu ou alors on
aurait pu bien sûr on aurait pu
consolider aussi par ses quatre en
empêchant des cinq c4 empêche des scènes
puisque aprilia la prise en d5 la noter
ici que l'intérieur la tour en plus
protège à deux ça c'est bien on peut
envisager ces quatre oui parce que ces
quatre peut menacer ses 5 on peut
essayer de décider de faire des poussées
comme ça peut-être que les noirs peuvent
pas prendre ici bon j'en prends le 6
alors là il ya deux prises possible
alors la prise positionnelle c'est de
prendre du plomb mesure pourquoi et bien
parce que on avait deux pions de doubler
et l'a enseigné on a deux options
potentiellement mobil 1 c'est mieux ils
sont côte à côte ces d'additionner on
ressent tout sans doute un bon coup ici
mais qui aurait quand même pu continuer
par cavalli c5 qui attaquent à la fois
des sept acquittements ses protégés mais
ça attaque aussi eu six qui lui est
attaqué aussi par la tour donc pas
facile à défendre d'ailleurs parce que
si on jouera f7 on peut doubler et là on
voit pas trop comment défend pas facile
donc au vu de cette variante
et bien finalement ta l'europe rendu fou
fou le 6 mai s'est pas positionné parce
qu'on a laissé les deux pions missile a
abandonné la défense du pion bessette
on a abandonné la défense effectivement
du pion baisse est tout à fait alors à
noter que sept
cette solution est sans doute au moins
bonne alors on va quand même voir
l'autre aussi ce qui se passe après
prendre six cavaliers ces cinq attaques
ici bien sûr que font que font les noirs
il ya une subtilité ses cavaliers des 4
on peut essayer cavaliers des quatre
bien sûr puisque en cas de prise du
cavalier bien sûr on n'atteint que 6
mais on perd le contrôle de ses 5 voilà
mais les blancs peuvent augmenter la
pression par fous ces quatre ici pas
facile pour les noirs ici ça perd en
fait le pion ans ce pur et perdu en fait
on peux pas le défendre
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi finalement
il prend quand même avec le fou il vaut
mieux avoir des peines doublées comme
s'ils ont perdu au moins pas toujours le
savait pas mais au moins on oublie les
un mois les prix ont doublé les a alors
à noter quand même un pour contrecarrer
un peu 7,7 jugement sur la position
il ya quand même ici pour le noir un
petit facteur c'est la paire de fou pour
l'instant bien de fou est souvent un
facteur mais il ya la casse et 5 qui
était une belle case invasion il ya un
fou qui tape bien ici il ya la
possibilité pourquoi pas plus tard de
pousser un f5
il ya des tours active et l'as vence le
développement blanche est toujours là
avec une tour à schwyz qui joue pas et
la possibilité quand même d'attaquer ici
ça c'est un bloc faible après ses pions
qui sont mal placés et puis ça c'est
aussi ça peut être l'objet d'une cible
alors ce pion est un tout petit peu
faible chez les blancs mais pas facile à
attaquer dans quel fou et puis ce pion à
deux peut s'avérer faible aussi il
faudrait titiller ce cavalier
peut-être mais ça affaiblit d'autres
kazemi non c'est pas simple donc x 6
alors câblée eux c'est 5 de meetings
voilà qui joue actif très bien il
améliore la position de ses pièces il a
fini son travail ici il va dans le camp
noir à noter qu'ils attaquent bessette
et 2,6 menaçant simplement de gagner
comme pion par exemple qu'elle est
décédée un avion ou cavaliers prendre 6
ps prend tout reprend gagné monsieur
aussi donc il faut réagir et talent
choisi le coup cavaliers des quatre
alors c'est la même idée que valeur si
les blancs prennent le cavalier c'est la
paix
ici du cavalier alors avec les d4 on
protège aussi le fou aux 6 à noter que
la menace s'est aussi de prendre ici et
ça oblige le cavalier à reprendre
puisque il n'est pas défendu ce cavalier
se caler csn qui est attaqué par le fou
donc ce qu'avait des quatre est pas mal
c'est un coup dynamique qui complique la
situation
ouais ok bon alors on se dit oui mais
attention le pion 17 n'est pas protégé
oui certes donc les blancs pourrait
prendre ici maintenant le pion 17 et
peut-être a pris maintenant attention ce
cas il est attaqué donc après apprend
apprend en plus on a ramené nos pions on
l'a ramené mon prêt du centre on a
rééquilibré nos pions avec une bonne
position
la plaisir souvent un petit peu il est
fou noir on doit être plus actifs
on voit exactement quels excès active
voilà un coucou forme et blanc puisque
qualité pas sortir les objets de
ressortir en a cinq
je suis obligé de jouer car il est assez
attention à fonder 4 et si je joue ça je
peux aussi jouer tenté x 4
si beau si faux car qu'est ce qui se
passe sur france 4
je regarde c'est possible faudra c'est
fou prendre cette chance
on peut prendre moi je prendrais plutôt
arcade puisque on élimine le fou et
après tout reprendre fou on à tourbes et
8 là par exemple tour des huit
lecavalier alors l'attention ailleurs
plus de casse du tout on peut pas même
pas mettre la tour ici puisque ya le fou
donc on est obligé de jouer quelque
chose comme torah 5 et voilà c'est là on
y est c'est la menace c'est celle là
c'est à dire que là le problème de cette
variante c'est toujours à la fin il ya
toujours fous ces cinq en fait c'est ça
le problème
il faut pas oublier ça donc après qu'un
l'épreuve et rend à prendre mais trois
fous des cinq en fait finalement la
menace c'est fou ces 5
voilà donc en fait c'est celle qui le
récupère la qualité donc c'est ça que
making veut éviter à tout prix
c'est pour ça qu'après cavaliers des
quatre il ne prend pas et puis ont
baissé de ton passé un piège en fait
c'est vrai piège de talent
à la fin il ya le petit coup la fin de
combinaison qui gagnent la qualité donc
il prend le fougueux 6 alors à noter que
sept sapeurs on peut pas avec les noirs
améliorer la position des pilotes de
toute façon puisque le cavalier ici est
en prise ces câbles et pour le ciss
échec de toute façon il faut reprendre
donc dû caler et maintenant il continue
son développement
ici me king jouet f5 attaquant le fou
aux six avec la tour on peut pas
défendre il va falloir encore bouger le
cavalier voyez comme ils le harcèle
alors on aurait pu ici tenter quelque
chose comme canalis et senc qu'est ce
qui se passe sur club les c5 qui est
protégé par le fou dans la tour prendre
7 et bien regardez tout reprendre 7 et
surprend on prend le cavalier avec
cavaliers plus fous contre tours ce qui
est mieux c'est plus fort est ici si les
noirs prennent le cavalier b 3 1 mais
simplement un premier set tranquille en
fait on a gagné
appuyons donc calais prend 1,6 fou et 5
il faut donc reculé c'est ce que fait
talent d'ailleurs puisqu'il vous
cavaliers c7 alors une impossibilité
pour thalys ils sont arrêtés de jouer
plus c'est simple puisque ça cloud mais
selon elle ça aurait obligé qu'un mali
prend mais ça donne le fou on n'a pas
forcément envie parce que déjà qu'on est
moins bien là à cause de ses pions fou
est supérieur aux cavaliers il reste que
le dominer ce fou il est quand même de
la bonne couleur en plus il défend la
faiblesse f2
il n'est pas attaquable par les pions il
est déjà de la couleur opposée des pions
f4 donc c'est un super fou face à une
cavale in qui va être un peu seul donc
c'est pas c'est pas possible donc avalé
f7 de la part qu'a laissé cette parlant
de la part de talent retour des 1 alors
ça c'est bien joué de making maintenant
qu'il a fini son travail sur cette
colonne il estime qu'il faut aller sur
la case 17 pourquoi parce que c'est là
qu'à se protéger par le fou facile à
envahir c'est l'endroit de pénétration
dans le camp ennemi si après on arrive
là mais on va risquer de ramasser tout
ce qui a ramassé sans compter les
menaces sur la dernière rangée sur la
question la huitième donc ici talent
prévient cette attaque par cavalli b5
l'intérêt de calais 5 c'est de jouer
cavalier ensuite en d6 ici attaquant le
fou est excellent et défendant le pion
mais ce serait une magnifique case pour
le cavalier est logique en même temps 17
et il ne fait pas en fait il aurait pu
donc ici hop
il aurait pu jouer ici talens coup il
est bien ce qu'on veut c'est un bon coup
ça oblige tout détruire a quasiment plus
fous des 3 et qu'est ce qui se passe sur
tous ses mythes
par exemple on fout des trois tours c8
et la tour alors je joue au 02 voilà ça
ça tours 2 khattak
khattak le fou on peut pas défendre donc
oui tour 17 ici tour des huit de la part
de talent donc oui en fait tour 2 suffit
en fait quand le tour deux tours 8
alors l'idée de talent ici bas c'est de
ces deux jours le seul coup finalement
pas ce qu'il faut il faut qu'il empêche
la pénétration et haïssent il permet
tour deux fois pas de case il va où le
faux nez c'est ça le problème
il n'a pas de case apprécié le cavalier
peut rentrer ça fait beaucoup quoi ça va
faire cher donc fait tourner vite pour
alléger la pression essayé d'échanger
cette tour alors est ce que les blancs
pourrait prendre
ici on sait quatre ans bessette pardon
est bien là et attention la flamme des
huit des six ses efforts ni fourchette
est la fourchette daries qui peuvent
doubler les tours aussi la question
alors on peut envisager bien sûr l'autre
possibilité il faut regarder c'est
l'atout la possibilité tour d2 un tour
d2 il n'y a pas de problème on serait
quasiment obligée de prendre prise
prises pour me voir jouer cavalier des
six on peut jouer qu'avec des sarts
attention parce que la tour
on peut sortir c'est un peu sortir oui
mais on va aider les noirs à s'activer
aussi on peut jouer fou h3 par exemple
pour garder un contrôle sur la tourbe
wolof ou des trois oui après on pourra
essayer de jouer des choses comme cavani
6 5 mais là tout renvoyer elle est mal
placée puisqu'elle ne peut pas prendre
en dix-sept le fou il peut pas venir en
quatre duels cavalli des biens'' cavani
enfin voila c'est une position où les
noirs semblent respirer quoi donc il
laisse pas faire ça surtout des huit il
joue ses cartes voilà plus actifs
maintenant il veut déstabiliser le
cavalier pourquoi pas créer des menaces
pour pour jouer pourquoi pas c'est
simple pourquoi pas après faire pression
sur bessette et puis avoir un candidat
un pion candidat donc cavalier des six
logique mais voyez grâce à ses 5 bat il
a un peu plus déstabilisé ce cavalier
potentiellement bon ça oblige tout
reprendre tour d'abord puisque le fou
s'il est attaqué bombay a moins le
métrage 3 mais il serait peut-être un
peu passif si on veut le mettre au
centre il faut d'abord prendre et signer
la tour ne serait plus défendu donc fou
prend food et 3 alors laissez bien
puisqu'on revient à la défense du pion
on garde la potentialité de jouer ici
ces cinq qui chasse le cavalier et on
domine ici regardez comme on domine les
cases du cavalier dé 6,1 grâce au fond
donc ce cavalier est un peu immobilisé
supériorité ici de fou sur lequel il
faut empêcher la poussée des six alors
voilà donc au bout des six pour empêcher
le fameux csn combien de voir donc la
tour d2 pas mal je menace à tout moment
de faire des trucs avec mon fou par
exemple si le roi venait en effet pas
moi en 8 on pourrait rien faire non g8
g20 g8 éventuellement pourrait faire
échec les prendre le fou bon c'est pas
forcément idéal mais on peut jouer on
peut jouer ces cinq pour peu joué ces
cinq aussi avec la place de les prendre
à 6 attaqué le cavalier puis on s'est
créé un pion passé sur le côté c'est
possible aussi tous ces sept bons mais
qui ne se pressent pas faut pas non plus
faire trop des changes si on veut gagner
jour toujours faire attention donc là il
améliore la position de son mois un
loyer up web de g73 f3 la meilleure
toujours la position de son roi quand
vous ne savez plus quoi faire vous avez
aux pièces au maximum qu'on est en
finale le roi ne craint plus rien il
faut l'activer c'est une pièce d'attac
il faut aussi veiller pas trop le
laisser sur une case où il pourrait
prendre un échec du cavalier mais oui
mais éventuellement voilà éventuellement
se mettre sur la couleur opposée celle
du fou c'est pas de la case f3 voilà
c'est la meilleure case pour leroy hill
et il est super seront ici puisqu'il
défend f4 il défend j'ai deux déjà il
est beaucoup plus active congères où il
défend n'est pas le cadre et en plus moi
il prend des cases au centre et il est
pas ni sous l'emprise d'un échec le
rapide du cavalier ni sous l'emprise
d'un échec du fou et encore moins de la
tour qui est encore très très loin de
faire quoi que ce soit tours 8 donc ils
activent justement sa tour de son côté
talent c'est l'heure de mettre en jeu
les pièces qui joue pas et un tour deux
proposent des changes mais il veut pas
bien sûr parce que les blancs saurez
beaucoup mieux en train et changent mais
il va pas trop avoir le choix longtemps
tour des deux cavaliers bessette de la
part de talent alors il vise sans doute
la case c5 qui bloquerait le pion ici
sur la couleur du foot ce qui peut être
un ou un coup défensif intéressant faut
4 alors ça ça force les changes détour
puisque on attaque à la fois le cavalier
et on propose un échange donc c'est très
difficile de parier les deux en même
temps on pourrait aurait pu tenter
éventuellement qu'elle est décisif c'est
possible on tourne en rond un peu mais
peut-être que le fou sera mieux on
décèle relation joue en dessin qu'on
aime moins
un passif dans d'étroits on est plus
actif au noeud papillon tapis si on va
essayer de pénétrer peut-être sur
l'autre colonne et attention ça a
toujours qui est un peu faible pour
l'instant on n'a pas mis l'accent dessus
mais ça va venir
regardez après fou et 4 pour prendre des
deux cavaliers prend des deux caves et
les c5
on l'avait vu tout à l'heure et
tranquillement mais making joue h4 alors
pourquoi h4 en général on n'est pas les
pions sur la couleur du fond adverse
mais là c'est différent parce qu'on peut
jouer g3 avec une grosse structure
solide tant que le roi est à proximité
ça est-ce que rien et surtout on
immobilise le pion de cases blanches ici
h5 isolé sur la couleur opposée du fou
le problème étant donc que ça
immobilisera le roi à sa défense ou
éventuellement le cavalier ou les
cavaliers - de mélange plus tard voilà
mais c'est ici la pas peur de se faire
échanger
d'ailleurs si les noirs ici prenez le
cavalier regarder on prendrait du
cavalier et puis on pousserait pas g3
simplement reviendrai là et ça
obligerait le roi venir au contact du
pion et on pourrait envisager de monter
sans en attendant et après on pourrait
revenir avec le cavalier ici consolider
et le roi va envahir les lames il sera
le premier les dames le roi noir aura du
retard
il y aura beaucoup de retard voire même
ne pourra jamais venir donc food et 6 de
la part de talent après h4h quatre fous
des 6es la regarder comme kelly a fait
un donc l'idée c'est de venir taquiner
un tac ici devenir la taquiner la
faiblesse ça y est c'est là où la
structure de pions regardez commence à
être mise en évidence par me king il a
transposé dans une finale où il est un
peu mieux alors il ya un deux trois
îlots de piocher les noirs de trois chez
les blancs aussi mais il ya aussi des
pions doublé donc c'est ce léger
avantage qui permet un making d'espérer
jouer pour le gain donc tous ces fous
ces sept
et là ça y est on y est voyez tac tout
est logique et maintenant ça oblige ici
le courbet le courage si ça n'a pas
d'autres
en fait il n'y a pas d'autres coups
échec cette folle cavale ya plein de
possibilités c'est ça qui est difficile
de cavalier blanc à cause de la
structure de pions noirs il a beaucoup
beaucoup de cases qui lui sont
accessibles petite répétition de coûts
voilà poussé deux cavaliers au cices
alors ça ce cavalier des quatre alors
menace à la fois effectivement calais
des quatre échecs et fourchette
mais surtout ils menacent en plus le
pion f4 ça fait deux menaces qui sont
parés avec un seul coup cavalier échec
protège la casse des quatre il faut
bouger le roi en recettes et regarder up
g3 ça y est alors à jouer chez 3 par
contre il se prive de la possibilité
d'attaquer ce pur mais lecavalier mais
c'est pas grave parce qu'avoir des
l'oeuf ou encore l'attaqué
à noter que le fouet alors une
magnifique pour ça parce que encore une
fois il va attaquer la faiblesse à
droite mais en plus avoir un rôle à
gauche parce que imaginer qu'ils
viennent en 2003 il peut en plus avoir
un oeil sur les dames
donc c'est magnifique sarr se fout va du
coup s'avérer extrêmement utile et le
roi blanc du coup va être supérieures à
son homologue noir puisque lui va
pouvoir se balader tandis que l'autre
sera à la défense de son pur h5
c'est ça qui fait la différence dans
cette finale donc allez j cède alors
attention on
né change surtout pas les cavaliers dans
cette position pourquoi parce qu'on a
les fous de couleur opposée avec en plus
la même quantité de pionner de côté on
peut dire que la pression serait nul
oui il faut garder les cavaliers si on
veut gagner donc cavalier cet échec
n'ont pas échec six échecs avec roissy 6
6 6 6 échecs pardon oui je dis bien
échec du four bien sûr roaa suite
et hop tu as que ça y est on se sent
trahi le cavalier attaque le four
attaque le pion b6 attaque le fou c'est
si ça oblige food et 8 seul coup c'est
un petit coup ça tient se tient mais
alors là on regardait autant que le foot
à l'heure dominique cailliez autant
maintenant regarder si ce cavalier qui
domine le fou toutes les cases du fou
sont prises par le cavalier temps il ce
courrier lui peut se balader où il veut
regardez maintenant toc
alors l'idée de re 4 mai sur ces
centralisée droit mais aussi homme c'est
de permettre le fou de venir faire
pression puisque après cavaliers aussi
ce pouf food et 1 oblige comme les g7
il est coincé talent et ça fait il se
fait vis et comment vit il se fait vis
et regardez comme c'est beau cette fin
de partie c'est vraiment alors là encore
c'est une partie à montrer dans les
écoles d'échecs parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est magnifique cavalier b4 attaque
maintenant le pion à 6 ça oblige les
noirs à jouer à 5
hop on revient tranquillement ça crée
une faiblesse parce que maintenant le
pion b5 b6 peut plus avancer le pion à 5
non plus ouais et puissant sur la
couleur opposée du fond blanc donc il
suffirait que le fougueux reçoit ans à 4
pour pouvoir là pour pouvoir les bloquer
définitivement
à noter que oui si le fou arriva en même
temps 17 il peut bloquer le cavalier
elle aura rien comme il est loin alors
il faut trouver un moyen maintenant pour
les blancs de transformer cette
écrasante position ici roy g8 câble et
c3 donc encore un coup de cavaliers bas
et ça laisse le on a envie de venir là à
velleron évidemment parce que si l'euro
le fou déstabiliser up bouffe bouffe
mais là cécile roy arrivé en 17e il
prendrait le fou puisqu'il a pas de
pataquès devient plus sur ippon il
aurait pas de case on peut imaginer
entre temps quand je jouais il sut
sortir le fou mais c'est paul besset
voilà alors ici alors l'idée c'est que
l'on veut jouer le roi sans que le
cavalier viennent ici parce que si
lecavalier les malins regarder hop on as
hellemmes dherse ça serait nous qui
aurions une faiblesse ici donc vite les
rois regardez vite les parts dans les
rangs vite les noirs viennent de
d'activer leurs droits mais je viens je
vais au centre ça y est ou ce belge en
pêche le cavalier de venir attaquer ma
faiblesse ont menacé d'entrer ses six
avec le roi donc il faut que le roi
alors oui parce que bien sûr la menace
ici c'est d'avoir une position écrasante
roi c6 et je reviens des cinq échecs et
le roi est obligé de jauron d'action
mais si ces voix là je gagne le cube et
6 avec le cavalier j'ai un pion passé je
vais vite adam
donc c'est pas possible il faut
absolument rejouer rodez cet échec au
bij le roi noir à choisir un camp crois
que cette poussée de on reviendra
toujours pour empêcher qu avait laissé
deux mois 17 encore un courrier et
plusieurs répétitions parce que valeo
gagne du temps comme ça fait oublier
qu'avec la pendule plus on joue deux
coups mieux c'est parce que ça nous
laisse plus de temps pour jouer pour la
suite et l' obsession ni varroase 6
alors c'est un coup responsable puisque
certes je menace
devenir en d5 échec de prendre le pion
v6 mais mais mais je permets aussi
cavalière scène qui peut venir prendre
lampions g3 donc c'est ce que fait
talent d'ailleurs mais regardez
simplement calais des cinq échecs ou
valleroy bon le mieux c'est de rester au
centre si c'est possible donc droit aux
six se comprend et simplement cavaliers
pro b 6 donc j'ai pas peur là ici de me
laisser prendre le pion g3 alors si les
noirs avaient pris ici le pion g3 on
aurait commencé ici sans doute tout de
suite a repoussé l'entretien ces cinq
ballottée que la prise de ce pion
effectivement ne crée pas de pions passé
immédiat et on voit que le roi noir peut
pas entrer dans le camp blanc toutes les
cases mais qu'est ce qui permettra
d'avancer sont si j'avance je me laisse
je laisse faire
roy 17 et où elle fout et après ses 6
607 on soit pas contestée au blanc la
progression on peut pas peut pas on peut
pas faire grand chose donc câbles hypron
v6 est là bas
tall finalement ne rentre pas dans cette
variante s'ils jouent plutôt qu'à
valider quatre échecs qui va essayer de
garder ses pièces au contact de ceux qui
ont passé mais ça c'est un quasiment l
aveu d'abandon et donc la voyez vous
avez eu la magnifique manoeuvre de
pénétration de making dans le camp
ennemi
donc la croix bessette s'aménage la
possibilité d'aller à dame est donc de
faire sacrifier tout de suite que le roi
noir interviennent pour empêcher ces
cinq mois c'est ce que fait talent
exactement
donc là maintenant on contrôler
l'avancée du pion mais regardez
magnifique alors ça c'est joli parce que
cavaler 17 contrôler la case c5 donc la
menace ces cinq échecs et il est protégé
par le fou à 4 donc l'accabler aussi ce
talent recontrôle la case c5 et la route
grâce et 8 comme on protège sa à noter
qu'on peut plus bouger ou valve fou n'y
a pas de case silva là il est coincé
alors il peut éventuellement encore
aller ici on peut pas bouger le cavalier
si vous vous serez perdu et le roi
mais il peut pas bouger en fait et tout
est pris à la menace c'est ça qui est
très forte puisque le cavalier et en
menace après on peut menacer
effectivement csn puisqu'en cas de prise
mais on reprend du cabinet simplement on
va prendre et roy prendre fou et ça
suffit pour gagner donc fou et 7 et en
faire regarder la pointe très jolie de
making c'est magnifique ce dernier coup
et tu l'a oublié celui-là tac
plouf alors non seulement ce pion que
toujours potentiellement aller à dame
pourquoi pas mais ce pur h5 va sauter
derrière c'est le pion f7 qui sautent le
pion h deviendra un pion passez donc la
seule solution pour les noirs sadjo
cavaliers g7 pour protéger toute force
le curage 5
on pourrait on voit bien que c'est hyper
passif c'est qu'en fait il ya échec
échec et la suit alors une autre
possibilité
après food et à ses deux tantes et
cavaliers c5 ce que cavaler c5
déstabilise un tout petit peu ce
lecavalier 17 qui serait sans doute
obligée de prendre en c5 et après avoir
passé cinq attention on a des fois que
le reposer mais en fait rien d'autre qui
aime qui coûte quand même gagné un temps
où froide et cette nouvelle le fou parce
que si le fou vendée 6 on peut pas
prendre et si le fou va en ses huit
simplement on sait le roi qu'on amène là
maintenant jouera des 6 et enfin on peut
prendre du roi ou alors on prend du
plomb parce que on l'a ensuite ou alors
on protège le pion c4 avec le fou aussi
way monsieur bien ça je pense ça suffit
parce que là maintenant que fond
on peut prendre on peut jouer je m'aime
pas si on peut pas jouer il faut prendre
cet échec je pense
il faut paraître cet échec tout à fait à
detroit et puis maintenant on y va
comment on arrête le pion c'est
difficile parce que le fou noir peut
difficilement se fait sur la bonne
diagonale
alors on peut parce qu'on joue f5 il
faut bien calculer parce que sur h6
maintenant food en algarve a juste le
temps h7
et attention oui mais attention parce
que les footeux couleurs opposées même
on a le temps simplement tout ça voilà
on doit protéger et on fait d'armes est
peut-être un peu plus simplement en
bloquant la possibilité d'effets six ans
joue avec cinq un petit peu avant tout à
fait alors sur food est un donc une
autre possibilité on va regarder un peu
cavalier g7 c5 tout simplement
alors non cépage etc on avait dit qu
avait laissé cinq c'est ça
car les pensées cinq rois princes et 5
donc maintenant roi 17 coûts
intermédiaires très intéressant fouet
fuite 3,8 des six est maintenant faut h5
menace ou procèdent qui garde le
contrôle sur ses 4 on va pas laisser
faire ça donc il faut absolument prendre
le pont c4 maintenant aux prises avec
échec
et oui mais si on prend avec échec eux
qu'on joue f5 on doit avoir des soucis
alors si on fait faux prend f7 roi des
trois on peut pas jouer en simple
puisqu'il vous prendrez h 30 faux projet
prend et peut revenir
non non donc il faut regarder la varende
qu'on a vu c'est à dire h scène qui
simplement f5 hc tac tac tac et on
ramène le roi on n'a pas peur que le roi
noir ici à y prendre suis là parce que
de toute façon on va prendre l'autre
pion aux sillons
voilà donc fin de partie ça s'arrête sur
food est un fait abandon magnifique
oui là la position finale et joli coin
il est un peu ballotté
attaquer à droite les attaques et à
gauche ouais puis les revenus à droite
voilà ça d'imposition qui finit par
craquer alors que le matériel est égal
donc on peut revenir sur le plateau pour
cette fin de partie alors c'est une
partie qui a eu lieu en 1975
voilà donc c'est un peu la grande
période de making il est au top donc
face à un seul championnat mikhail
talent qui est encore extrêmement
redoutable puisqu'il aura été redoutable
jusqu'à jusque dans les années 80 elle
n'a pas de battre tous les meilleurs à y
compris les champions du monde il avait
juste des preuves de santé pour garder
la distance
oui oui on avait été opéré d'un rein il
n'avait qu avait des difficultés
physiques qui ont pas mal entraver sa
deuxième partie de carrière après son
titre de champion du monde
tout à fait voilà donc sur cette partie
technique offert au revoir on a chez
vous si il faut s'aider genre de partie
il faut étudier si vous voulez
progresser aux échecs mais c'est rien
qu'à regarder ses biens déjà et donc on
vous dit au revoir pour une autre
émission plus tard sur des google tv
pour voir les champions des chèques et
autres émissions
merci du rhum merci stéphane au revoir à
bientôt